this video is brought to you by
curiositystream
hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion so last episode we ran through
the complete history of the FTX
situation to sum it all up a man named
Sam bankman freed founded a crypto hedge
fund and exchange worth 37 billion
dollars it had investments from Big
players such as BlackRock and
endorsements from celebrities in the end
it was all a bit of a Ponte scheme ran
by Sam and his girlfriend and a bunch of
their friends in the Bahamas investors
and customers lost billions in the
disaster last time we left off Sam was
under police surveillance in the Bahamas
and was still Tweeting about making it
up to customers but today we'll cover
some major updates since then from
leaked messages to criminal
investigations as well as some inside
information on the full extent of the
company's mess
called Fusion TV
[Music]
so after the dust had settled from the
original shock of the bankruptcy and the
wild story leading up to it ftx's new
CEO John Ray III took a good look at
their books and what he saw was
unbelievable it was just a chaotic
fraudulent mess
in his report John would state that in
his 40 years of experience quote never
in my career have I seen such a complete
failure of corporate controls and such a
complete absence of trustworthy
financial information the concentration
of control in the hands of a very small
group of inexperienced unsophisticated
and potentially compromised individuals
this situation is unprecedented
and that is really saying something
because John sorted out the bankruptcy
of Enron in 2001.
so part of the issue at John John Ray
the new CEO has talked about is how
is keeping track of these assets whether
they're in Bahamas or in the U.S and who
has the right to really oversee those is
one of the issues and it goes back to
the beginning days of fgx and so the
mismanagement as John Ray has described
it and nobody really knows where the
assets are at this point so they're
trying to untangle this web at the
moment
so what exactly made it so bad
hold on to your seats because it's wild
FTX didn't even know exactly how much
cash it had on hand or how many people
even worked for the company let's take a
look at some highlights from the 30-page
report
one employees submitted payment requests
over chat a random manager would accept
or reject those reimbursements with an
emoji
number two Alameda research gave Sam a
one billion dollar personal loan and
also according to the Wall Street
Journal FTX raised 450 million dollars
from some big investors Sam said that
this was supposedly supposed to help
grow the business and allow them to
engage more with Regulators but in
reality 300 million dollars of that
money was instead siphoned off to Sam
lovely
number three very few records were kept
most decisions were made over chat with
the messages automatically being deleted
after a certain time
number four FTX a company valued at 32
billion dollars never had any board
meetings and neither did most of their
subsidiaries
number five management had no idea about
how much cash was on hand at any given
time or even where all of the cash was
number six FTX didn't keep proper
records of who they employed employees
and contractors co-mingled throughout
the different companies without proper
documentation of how they spent their
time certain employees can't be located
number seven corporate funds were used
to purchase personal real estate and
employees and Executives put their own
names on the homes that they purchased
with company funds sources also state
that several of ftx's luxury properties
in the Bahamas were purchased with 50
ftt and 50 FTX stock
and more news just in over the past two
years Sam's parents and Senior
Executives spent 300 million dollars on
luxury properties in the Bahamas
what's worse is that just in September
2022 Sam said that FTX had 5.5 billion
dollars in quote less liquid crypto
tokens the real value was only 659
thousand dollars
so at this point one major question
remains how did so many of the smartest
people fall for this well aside from the
financial sector being fueled by a Mania
from low interest rates and cheap money
according to Fortune Sam would send
investors a document that was too good
to refuse
it was a spreadsheet that included
Revenue daily uses and expenses what it
didn't mention was Alameda it also gave
the impression that FTX was a rapidly
growing company with solid financials
going from 15 million dollars in Revenue
in 2019 when it was founded all the way
to over 1 billion dollars in 2021
in reality these were sales documents
with no true Accounting in the end it
didn't matter because investors just saw
the dollar signs and they were drooling
and wanted a piece of the action
it's turned out of the latest around FTX
a court Following over the weekend
showing the crypto exchange owes its 50
largest creditors more than three
billion class action lawsuits against
FTX and the celebrity promoters are
flying Shaquille O'Neal and Tom Brady
are just some of the celebrities Under
Fire
a lawsuit filed by the attorney Adam
Moskowitz claims quote the deceptive FTX
platform maintained by the FTX entities
was truly a house of cards a Ponzi
scheme where the FTX entities shuffled
consumer funds between their opaque
Affiliated entities using new investor
funds obtained through Investments and
Loans to pay for interest to the old
ones an attempt to maintain the
appearance of liquidity it goes on to
say that FTX use some of the biggest
names in sports and entertainment to
raise funds and drive American consumers
to invest in the Ponzi scheme we
discussed this more in the cold fusion
podcast called through the web so check
it out if you haven't I'll leave it in
the description below
according to the news Outlet the
information some Venture Capital firms
are also considering suing Sam
on the 20th of November 2020 Joe Biden
would call for changes to Global Bitcoin
and crypto rules meanwhile the United
States House committee on Financial
Services plans to conduct hearings on
the FTX disaster in December Sam bankman
freed is set to testify
unfortunately Maxine Waters who will be
in charge of the hearing appears to be
cozy with Sam
the two have also met before the
collapse in April of 2022 this was to
discuss crypto among other things
so what about the possible government
corruption well an attorney John Deaton
has launched a petition to investigate
the ties between the SEC chair Gary
Gensler and Sam
it's recently come to light that Gary
had a 45-minute call with Sam in March
to discuss a new trading platform that
was supposed to be approved by the SEC
this Behavior has been called unusual by
people familiar with the matter Fortune
has stated that Washington DC insiders
presume that Gary will be grilled by
Congress and is quote in a corner U.S
senator Josh Howley has also demanded
that top Democrats and Biden officials
release emails regarding FTX Alameda
research and Sam bankman freed the aim
is to determine whether Sam's 37 million
dollars in political donations to
Democrats may have created pressure on
Regulators to be lenient with FTX
if anything actually comes from all of
this remains to be seen
so will the victims get their money back
as Robert Frenchman a partner at New
York law firm marcusi Frenchman puts it
FTX customers will have to get in line
with the rest of the creditors because
there are no special protections for
customers of unregistered crypto firms
like FTX John Ray who is currently going
through the books of Sam's Empire says
that there isn't even a single document
detailing all the companies deposit it
so really it's not looking great some
people may get funds back but it's
likely to be Sense on the doll
and finally there have been some late
messages between Sam and a Vox reporter
Sam admits that his efforts to appear
moral during the company's Heyday were
quote a dumb woke game we westerners
play where we say all the right
shibboleths and so Everyone likes us
he also said f Regulators they make
everything worse
and then he goes on to blame his then
girlfriend Caroline who was running
Alameda he states that essentially FTX
didn't lose money the money was loaned
to Alameda and they lost it Sam just
thought that Alameda had more collateral
than they did we know we can't trust the
guy but if we do give him the benefit of
the doubt it's safe to say that with no
accounting department this is no
surprise
so where was this lawyer well Sam had
been blabbing so much after the collapse
that his lawyer Paul Weiss dropped him
as a client and I don't blame him Sam is
almost impossible to legally defend at
this point
as for Caroline there's rumors that
she's fleeing to Dubai a country that
doesn't have an extradition treaty with
the US
but these claims are unsubstantiated at
this point
so in the end behind all the smoke and
mirrors Sam's multi-billion Dollar
Empire functioned like so they used
emojis to hash out expenses Sam received
a one billion personal loan important
decisions were made over chat and
deleted there were no board meetings and
the company had no idea how much cash
they had or who even worked there if
billions of dollars of consumer money
wasn't wasted this all would have been
pretty funny
collapses of other crypto firms are
likely to happen with Gemini being the
most recent in the future if any other
major news breaks and you guys want to
know about it I could make another
episode anyways that's all for today and
I think that's where I'm going to leave
the story ah and last week Sam was
spotted roaming free in the Bahamas
Sammy oh Sammy my boy you may want to be
careful out there buddy there's a lot of
people that you pissed the [ __ ] off my
boy you may want to take some
precautionary
you can already see some pretty Stark
differences guys here on the island is
FTX unwinds the lit up sign that said
FCX when we were here back in August
that's gone we also stopped by fgx
headquarters that parking lot was
essentially empty security guards shoot
us away pretty quickly we also saw a car
leaving those offices with four young
people we couldn't confirm that they
were indeed FTX employees but they
rolled up the window wouldn't talk to us
wouldn't make eye contact and sped away
pretty quickly
there's been a lot of business and
financial news recently Facebook is
facing a myriad of problems and has laid
off over 11 000 staff I've made an
episode that discusses exactly what's
happening and interestingly it can all
be traced back to 2005. if you're
interested and want to find out more you
can watch it now on nebula nebula is a
streaming platform made by creators for
creators it allows me to experiment with
different kinds of content without
having to worry about demonetization or
the algorithm and best of all for you
guys it's ad-free nebula features
YouTube's best educational creators like
bright Sun films real engineering and
polymatter nebula is partnering with
curiositystream and we have a deal where
if you sign up with the link below not
only do you get access to
curiositystream but you'll also get
nebula for free it's not a trial you'll
have it as long as you're a curiosity
stream member curiosity stream has
thousands of documentaries anything from
ancient Rome and Stalin to space and
quantum physics and Nature Documentaries
there's a little bit of something for
everyone for a limited time curiosity
stream is offering 26 off their annual
plan that's less than 15 per year for
both curiosity stream and nebula you're
not going to find a better deal in
streaming it's a great way to support my
channel and educational content as a
whole so click the link in the
description or go to the URL clicking
that link really helps my channel so
thank you
all right so that's it from me my name
is [ __ ] and you've been watching cold
fusion take a look around on this
channel and see if you like anything
else
thanks for watching and I'll catch you
again soon for the next episode I'll
play you guys all out with a track that
I'm working on now cheers guys have a
good one
[Music]
[Music]
listening
[Music]
cool Fusion it's me thinking